[Music]
a fairer society a more
sustainable society a more democratic society
these are the three axes the three fibers
of the dna of political ecology is
actually you can't separate them and
christine and philippe lambert swinton
john all actions  Europeans then it
can be a legislative action adopted
votes or spending money or
raising money must obey the double
bind of reducing our
ecological footprint and reducing inequalities
if you screen all political action
there  in fact change you
politics completely and so if you
want what we want is change
the framework
change the frame of reference germany
france indicates from cairo i think
more and more people are realizing
in society that the choices that are
facts at European level are crucial
absolutely crucial if we want to
influence our future, that is to say
have sovereignty now the
question is is what we s  We are
able to reconcile the choices made
at European level with the general interest, whether
we like it or not, if we
look at the last thirty years,
well, the political choices in Europe
have benefited only one category of
the population,
these are the holders of  capital
[Music]